and our shoutout tonight for an
investigative reporter at the San Diego
union-tribune whose work is now being
credited by federal prosecutors as being
the spark that led to the indictment and
conviction of a five turn Republican
congressman who faces prison and later
this month plans to resign his position
it was a thousand dollars spent on video
games that led to the downfall of a
popular California Republican
congressman congressman Duncan Hunter
blamed his teenage son saying he
mistakenly build some thirteen hundred
dollars to his campaign instead of using
the family's personal credit card but at
the San Diego Union Tribune reporter
Morgan cook wasn't buying that excuse as
she discovered other questionable
expenditures in the records the
congressman had filed we search for oral
and facial surgery we saw a new garage
door
there were strange patterns of charges
lots of gas stations lots of grocery
stores just a fast-food a $229 charged
at the star trader store at Disneyland
that the congressman claimed was for
food and beverages for the campaign so I
call and I'm like what kind of food do
you guys had and they said well we have
Pez and a Star War themed rice krispies
treat I was like wow somebody's gonna
have a tummy ache prosecutors would
later document of $9,200 trip to Italy
for hunter and his wife Margaret who
also pleaded guilty to a criminal count
along with traveled to Hawaii resorts in
Arizona money spent in Washington
allegedly to pay for a series of
extramarital affairs even $600 in
airfare for the family pet rabbit named
Egbert Cook says she knew almost
immediately she was onto something big
you know we couldn't really let it go
it's like every question we answered
there was another question another
question and it
we looked there was another question so
he couldn't really let up hunter first
elected in 2008 and succeeding his
father of the same name was a well-known
and popular figure in the halls of
Congress and as prosecutors closed in he
said he was being investigated for what
were only accounting mistakes calling it
a witch-hunt aimed at him because he was
an outspoken defender of President Trump
they could try to have a political
agenda as our law enforcement as a US
government I think we've seen with
strong and and what the FBI and the DOJ
have been doing let's let them expose
themselves for what they are and then
that's a politically motivated group of
folks but earlier this month the
congressman changed his to pleading
guilty to one count of conspiracy to
convert campaign funds to personal use
likely now facing time in prison when he
is sentenced next year I failed to
monitor and account for my campaign
spending I made mistakes and that's what
today was all about the federal
prosecutor on the case Phil Halpern said
there was nothing political about it
that the investigation began only after
he read the reporting by Morgan Cooke in
the San Diego union-tribune the fact is
that the case began when Morgan Cooke
published an article in the UT I read
that article I discussed it with Emily
Allen and then mark Conover I went to
the FBI and we said look at this is
there a case and after that we went we
consulted with people in DOJ who in this
administration made the decision you
know to indict representative hunk
hunter nothing could have been more
apolitical than the process that was
involved here in fact today in many ways
is a triumph for the press and shows the
importance of having a free press that
not only can the people rely on but that
the Department of Justice can turn to
for guidance
Cooke was one of the reporters outside
the courthouse and was stunned to hear
what the prosecutor had to say about her
I think that's what I heard but that
doesn't sound like something that I
would hearing it was a very much caught
off guard because usually when people
call us out it's not to tell us a great
job we did and how much we helped and
how important we are it Cook became an
overnight journalism sensation her
reporting cited by the networks and
national newspapers a major career break
I think it would take a lot for me to
leave San Diego I think I could still
learn a lot here I can still grow here I
can still do the work that I'm capable
of here and it's a really special
newsroom because everyone is on everyone
else's team and they helped carry me if
I could do it better with help they
contributed their skill and I've just
been really lucky to be in a newsroom
where I have colleagues who support me
and support this work and are willing to
give what they can to see that Morgan
Cooke told me she survived one newspaper
she worked for closing down another one
let her go but she hung in there and
clearly has made quite a name for
herself doing the kind of hard-hitting
work we just don't see enough of anymore
that's our program for tonight thanks
for joining us and best wishes this
holiday season from all of us Rhonda
Ariel Jennifer Alex and our incredibly
talented technical crew we'll see you
back here next week good night